well as nevada tries to transition from  a record number of people on  unemployment we're now learning just how  much fraud actually  clogged up the system governor sisilak  says money to renovate our outdated  unemployment software from the  legislature will certainly help but  he told 8 news now that fraudulent  claims were a major problem all over the  country but especially here in nevada  dieter is a major problem i think anyone  can deny that  but you're finding out across the  country that the estimates are fifty  percent  of the cases that were applied for  adidas benefits were fraudulent  i mean hundreds of millions of dollars  were applied for and money got paid out  on fraudulent claims  and we need to do more in concert with  the attorney general department of  justice to prosecute those people  nevada is using federal funds to help  modernize our unemployment system